[Music]
our main story tonight concerns water it
is not just the one thing that your
house plant needed that you couldn't
even provide it's also the engine that
once powered this classic toy what's
this crazy thing but it's the whammo
water wiggle you've never seen anything
like it just hook up to a hose and look
a new fun game it's practically alive
you never know what the water wiggle
will do next yes the water wiggle you'll
never know what it'll do next except
kill some people because that's what the
water wiggle did it killed multiple
people and it was recalled that's right
we are less than two minutes into this
piece and i've already hit you with a
trademark john oliver sad fact
now
water is obviously vital to all life on
earth our bodies are essentially bags of
bones and meat suspended in water but
already 3.6 billion people nearly half
the world's population live in areas
that suffer water scarcity at least one
month each year and while this is
clearly becoming a problem everywhere
tonight we're going to focus on the
american west where the last several
decades have seen a record-breaking
drought the southwest is actually going
through its driest 22-year period since
800 a.d that is as far back as the data
goes which is already pretty startling
partly because i cannot believe that
someone back then was even keeping
drought records
it was probably the 9th century version
of me some lanky nearsighted dweeb who
squealed i'll be the official drought
daddy
i'll count the wets
and this drought has had massive impact
on the colorado river in particular
which is a key source of water for most
of the southwestern states
22 years of drought combined with
exploding populations in colorado and
throughout the southwest have led to
record low levels at both lake powell in
utah and lake mead outside las vegas
where an expanding white ring of mineral
deposits is probably the most visual
evidence of the river's decline it's
dire
the situation along the colorado river
is dire and i'm not sure it's going to
get better uh ever
wow
that is a bleak thing to hear an
environmental expert say but then the
news here is bleak water levels in lake
mead have now fallen so much that you
may have seen authorities have found
human remains there twice in just one
week
which really freaked me out until i
remembered that i dumped that hitchhiker
in lake mahavi not like me so i'm good
and while you would like to think a
situation this dire would cause people
to be more mindful of our water usage
instead we're seeing stories like this
right now it's an empty plot of land
covered with brush but if developer
regent properties gets the go ahead
the open desert will be transformed into
this the 750 million dollar thermal
beach club under the current plan the
developer wants to build 326 luxury
homes here at the site all surrounding a
20-acre surfing lagoon that's right a
20-acre surfing lagoon in the middle of
the california desert one of at least
four new surf lagoons proposed out there
that is just monumentally stupid i'm
honestly surprised they didn't go even
further not only do we have surfing
lagoons we also have a wall of
constantly flushing toilets a hose that
runs all day in the middle of a concrete
parking lot and of course wet frank a
man that we pay to dump buckets of water
on himself all day keep it up frank we
stand a damp legend
and while development like that is
obviously not ideal it is depressingly
consistent with our approach to water
out west because it has been a history
of denial and wishful thinking
especially around the colorado river
that is now crashing into harsh reality
so tonight let's take a look at our
water shortage how it's been impacted by
the choices that we've made and what we
can do about it and let's start with how
the colorado river is managed because a
lot of the problems that we're seeing
today can be traced back to decisions
that were made a century ago
this precious resource is allocated
based on a 1922 agreement called the
colorado river compact
once the river basin states agreed on
their fair shares they each established
a seniority system
first in time first in right it's true
seven states got together and carved up
all the water in the river essentially
letting people lay claim to it through a
complex system of calling dibs and look
i've got no problem with dibs in
principle it's a great way to figure out
who gets the last slice of pizza or the
pink starbursts or the cutest baby at
the hospital i don't care if he gave
birth to her i called dibs that one is
mine
but it is a weird way to divide up
something as important as water the
colorado river compact serves the
foundation for what is known as the law
of the river which sounds less like a
set of water management agreements and
more like an animated buddy cop movie
starring a trout and a bear voiced by
two actors who are both wildly
anti-semitic
but but there were a few major problems
with how the compact was set up right
from the start first mexico wasn't
included and even though it is today the
river essentially runs dry by the time
it gets across the border and the
compact also didn't specifically address
the water needs of the more than two
dozen native american tribes who depend
on the river which is pretty shitty
especially as those tribes do have the
most senior water rights given that they
were in a very real sense here first
they have the ultimate dibs
but even so tribes have had to struggle
to get those water rights actually
quantified on paper and even then to get
the infrastructure they need in order to
access it and for many tribes those
fights are still happening but but it
wasn't just about who the compact left
out another key flaw was that right from
the start it allocated more water than
actually existed water supplies are
measured in acre feet and the compact
divided uprights to 15 million acre feet
of water even though the river only
carries around 12 to 13 million and to
be clear they knew this was a problem at
the time the explorer and scientist john
wesley powell warned in 1893 there is
not sufficient water to supply these
lands but the [ __ ] map
never stopped just 10 years ago in a
major study by the federal government
states forced the modelers to add
so-called magic water
extra water that existed in the computer
model only which is just absurd and not
only because magic water sounds like a
euphemism for urine used exclusively by
bjork it's me
bjork sometimes you have to make your
magic water
but
it takes forever to get out of this
schwann
and i do get why states might want to
pretend there is more water than there
is because they want continued growth
and economic development and nobody
wants to be the bad guy pointing out the
fundamental problem with that just
listen to a reporter pressing a
representative of southern nevada's
water authority on how they can justify
growth in the face of looming water
scarcity
but something's got to give i mean you
can't just keep expanding the population
size with the dwindling water supply i
mean that that's just not sustainable
that's just human nature i mean that
really kind of goes back to manifest
destiny it goes back to sort of this
american dream you're going to continue
to see people moving to the desert
southwest so from our perspective as
water managers it is up to us to make
sure that we're able to meet the demands
of our community regardless of what our
numbers might be
okay
so there was a lot there including the
phrase manifest destiny which as we all
know only has good connotations you know
i got a self-published book about my
struggle or i really want to impress
jodie foster or hello my name is ted
cruz no red flags there at all but again
you can understand why he feels the need
to respond that way nobody wants to be
the one having to deliver bad news but
the immovable fact is cities in the
desert can't grow without limit and hard
sacrifices will have to be made which
brings us to another fundamental tension
here specifically between farmers and
cities because farmers and ranchers were
out west much earlier than most american
cities were established meaning they
have senior water rights and they use
them agriculture uses about 70
of the colorado river water and look
obviously agriculture needs water and no
one wants a situation where we create
food shortages but it is worth knowing
in some places farmers are incentivized
to use their allocation to a truly
nonsensical degree many states along the
river have rules promising to confiscate
water rights if water users don't
maximize their use basically use it or
lose it and that has ingrained certain
habits just listen to this farmer in
arizona explaining why he chose to grow
a particularly water intensive crop
well i just been farming it
this alfalfa you got to keep farming it
to keep the water and that's why i was
mainly doing it was to hang on to the
water
okay first i don't know who was filming
him there
but that camera is simply too close back
up and give that man some space
that's just too much face
but second he farmed alfalfa just so he
could hold on to his water rights which
feels ridiculous the only more absurd
way he could have used that water in
that field is if he'd also planted wet
frank
great work frank the soggy prince did it
again
so for all those reasons many related to
the compact's original over allocation
the colorado river is shrinking but what
that is leading to now is water uses
increasingly turning to another major
water source groundwater now groundwater
is exactly what it sounds like water
under the ground it slowly collects in
aquifers beneath the earth's surface
accumulating when rain snow melts and
other natural water sources seep into
the ground but importantly some of these
aquifers took thousands if not millions
of years to fill so if we pump them dry
they're not coming back anytime soon but
that's not always reflected in our
policies take arizona for instance in
eighty percent of the state there are no
laws protecting how much water is taken
from the ground and when you have no
limits it is unsurprisingly a
free-for-all
over the past five years farmlands have
increased by almost a third in arizona
the number of wells has risen from 43 to
123 in wilcox alone all they have to do
is buy the land to have access to as
much free water as they want in this
area there there's no rules
down so your client can pump
as much water they could they could
drill
a well every 10 foot all around this
place no limit
yeah that's not great is it partly
because drilling that many wells means
they're going to pump a ton of
groundwater out and also because if your
dog is trying to tell you that timmy has
stuck down a well which well rusty there
are hundreds of them which [ __ ] well
you have to give me more than our here
where's the boy
and it is not just arizona big farming
operations have long been pumping ground
water in the san joaquin valley in
california and it has had some pretty
severe consequences when this much water
is pumped out of the aquifer below
ground the clay between the pockets of
water collapses and the ground starts to
deflate like a leaky air mattress the
sinking is buckling the walls of
irrigation canals damaging pipes
creating giant sinkholes and cracking
homes this bridge has dropped so much
the water will soon flow over it instead
of under it yeah it's true and this is
not a new problem a scientist in
california once marked just how much the
land had sunk from 1925 to 1977 on a
telephone pole and that is a startling
drop although if you didn't know what
that was measuring you would be pretty
confused it looks like someone was
measuring the shrinking height of an
elderly giant with osteoporosis
but in recent years as large farming
operations have drilled deeper and
sucked up more water they've been
escalating impacts for the shallower
wells that families use last year in
california nearly a thousand shallow
household wells went dry and for anyone
who has ever lost one it can be a real
burden
it's where we catch our water so we can
flush toilets
get up in the morning take two bottles
of rain water put it in a coffee pot
my fiance will come in she'll help me
wash my hands
and then we'll take this water recycle
it
put it in a bucket out there until it
gets enough so we can flush the toilet
what about showering
well usually
we have to go into town uh to one of my
friend's house and if i can't go to my
friend's house you'll see some guys that
there's ads even on craigslist to be
able to take a shower five bucks take a
shower that kind of stuff that's what
kind of place it is around here
wow
using craigslist to take a shower that
is legitimately horrifying how do you
even write an ad for that without it
sounding suspicious seeking shower for
five dollars 34 year old adult non-creep
looking for fellow non-creepy adults to
allow me to use their shower this is not
a euphemism there's a water shortage and
i genuinely just want to get washed
again not a euphemism this isn't sexual
in any way i will happily pay five
american dollars for the shower you
can't watch you can't tape it you can't
be weird i'm just gonna come into your
house hand you a five dollar bill get in
the shower wash my hair and body as
quickly as possible and then leave or
while making the least amount of eye
contact possible we won't talk or have
any conversation ideally you'll forget
this whole thing ever happened actually
you know what i don't know the way any
of this is sounding so i'm just going to
stay dirty forever please do not contact
me with unsolicited services or offers
and perhaps
perhaps the most important thing
to know about groundwater is that it's
not totally independent of surface water
at all these are often part of one
intertwined hydrological system so when
you pump groundwater it can ultimately
dry up rivers the connection between
groundwater and surface water is one of
those alarming connections that we just
choose to forget you know like the one
between elizabeth moss and scientology
it's so much easier just not to really
think about it
so to recap for decades now we've been
using more water than the colorado river
has even as we have rapidly depleted
critical groundwater supplies and when
it comes to responding to this crisis
places have gone in very different
directions one of the best actors and
you are not going to believe this is
actually las vegas which i know
automatically feels weird because when
you think of vegas you probably think of
it as a place that uses water for things
like this how you doing
[Music]
i mean honestly i feel genuinely bad for
that fountain no drop of water ever
dreamed of one day being forced to dance
to the friend's theme for a bunch of
drunk vegas tourists no one told them
life was gonna be this way
but the thing is despite looking
extremely wasteful the bellagio's
fountain actually isn't it uses water
that's too salty to drink and annually
only uses as much water as would
irrigate just eight acres of alfalfa and
that is just one tiny way that the
people of vegas have learned to conserve
water they've also banned new lawns and
ornamental grass there which should save
about 10 billion gallons a year and
overall even though the populations the
vegas metro area grew by 34
between 2002 and 2013 its use of
colorado river water actually dropped by
over a quarter so vegas could actually
be something of a model for other places
when it comes to water conservation and
literally nothing else
but unfortunately not everywhere is
taking it that seriously with the worst
example being utah home of both the utah
jazz and their mascot jazz bear who
answers the question what if wiley
coyote was a jock who also wanted to
murder me in my sleep
crush me king
utah's residents use the most water of
any western state and nowhere is this
more true than saint george which has
become one of the fastest growing metro
areas in the country with per person
water consumption among the highest not
only does st george have very cheap
water rates their county which is in the
desert to remember has at least a dozen
golf courses including these and golf
courses use a [ __ ] ton of water they are
pretty much the dumbest possible thing
to put into the middle of the desert
other than of course burning man and
and while utah has recently passed some
new laws encouraging conservation
they've also been pursuing a billion
dollar pipeline to bring in what some in
utah insist is additional surplus water
from lake powell a surplus that anyone
who so much as looks at that lake would
know simply does not exist and i know
that that seems wildly irresponsible on
utas part and that is because it is
though to be fair it is still not the
worst idea they've had because just
watch this video from the governor of
utah in response to drought conditions
there just last year
we need more rain and we need it now
we need some divine intervention that's
why i'm asking utahns of all faiths to
join me in a weekend of prayer june 4th
through the 6th
by praying collaboratively and
collectively asking god or whatever
higher power you believe in for more
reign we may be able to escape the
deadliest aspects of the continuing
drought
wow
you know utah is desperate when they ask
all faiths to join in a prayer
i'm asking you tons of all faiths
whether that's the mormon one or one of
the many wrong ones to
collectively pray to the christian god
and the false deities the rest of your
worship form or reign so that we can
solve this crisis before those of you
who have not accepted jesus christ into
your heart burn in the fires of eternal
hell
so what can we do about all of this well
we can start by acknowledging some
uncomfortable truths first states like
utah are not going to be able to use the
full amount of water that they think
they're entitled to primarily because
that full amount never actually existed
in the first place but it is not just
utah no state can continue using water
the way they've gotten used to experts
suggest it might help actually not to
use the word drought at all anymore
which sounds temporary and instead use
the term eridification as a better way
to describe what might be a long-term
drawing of the american west so we need
to be incentivizing conservation and
water efficiency especially when it
comes to agriculture and stop with our
magical thinking toward water which has
been depressingly common throughout
history during a drought in the 90s city
officials in ventura california decided
to study the possibility of hauling
icebergs from the polar caps and
planting them off the county shores one
proponent even suggested we'd have to
wrap the iceberg with a diaper
to collect the melting iceberg water
more recently arizona passed a
resolution to study building a pipeline
from the mississippi river to the
colorado river and if you've ever seen a
map of the united states
you may have noticed that the
mississippi river is all the way over
here and arizona is all the way over
here so to do that you need a pipeline
that's over a thousand miles long and
the only way that idea could get any
dumber is if the pipeline was also
somehow wrapped in a diaper don't worry
everyone chase is on the case
the fact is states need to start working
together to cut back on their collective
water use and some have tried small
steps in arizona home remember to our
close-up alfalfa farmer they recently
changed their use it or lose it rules to
allow for more conservation and in
california in 2014 they passed the
sustainable groundwater management act
to try and bring groundwater pumping
under control but it is just not enough
and that may well be why something very
big happened just a week ago because the
government dropped a bombshell on the
colorado river states telling them they
have 60 days to create an emergency plan
to stop using between two and four
million acre feet of water in the next
year which is a massive amount or the
agency will use its emergency authority
to make the cuts itself that is a
drastic move but we are in a drastic
situation so let's hope those states get
to work in the next two months and come
up with a decent plan because we
desperately need to prepare for a much
drier future in the american west and do
it more equitably this time because it
is imperative that we learn from our
past mistakes and for anyone who still
thinks that this is something we can
just pray our way out of
i actually have a special message from a
very special guest
[Music]
hi
it's me
god
i know i don't often do this but i i
just wanted to appear in person to make
one thing perfectly clear
you can't pray your way out of a drought
frankly i'm insulted you even asked me
you got yourself in this [ __ ] mess
get yourself the [ __ ] out of it
i gave you plenty of water it's not my
fault you wasted it building surfing
lagoons and golf courses in the middle
of a [ __ ] desert
utah
your capital is salt lake city
it's next to a salt lake
a lake
of salt
take the [ __ ] hint
so no
i will not be answering your prayer for
rain
for the record i've only ever ever
answered one prayer little timmy
pendleton wanted a hess truck for his
birthday in
1986
and i made sure he got one the kid just
really seemed to want that truck and you
know maybe i felt bad about killing both
his parents with that tornado
i don't
there's so many things i'd rather talk
about to you than your stupid stupid
water usage
like
the meaning of life
which animal i created by mistake
guinea pigs by the way the point is
i want humans of all faiths
to come together and act like rational
[ __ ] adults when it comes to water
use
heed my words my children
and conserve the once bountiful gifts of
rivers and lakes which i created for you
on earth
now
[ __ ] off
[Music]
[Applause]
you